la fracture numérique est donc en débat
dans la voix est libre c'est la seconde
partie tout de suite avec lilian melet
et ses invités devienne partie de la
voie est libre effectivement consacré
aux oubliés d'internet avec patrice joly
président du conseil départemental de
lanières cédric colson président de pc
light ludovic rochette vice président du
conseil départemental de côte-d'or et
benoît ville au président de la cgpme de
côte-d'or un mot parce qu'effectivement
on a beaucoup parlé de l'opérateur
orange patrice joly on va expliquer
quand même pourquoi parce qu'ils sont
quand même en situation c'est quand même
eux qui écrase de marché globale sur le
territoire ruraux seraient caire sont
eux en effet qui montrent qu'ils ont les
trolls cas où peut-être les quatre
cinquièmes du marché donc c'est pour ça
effectivement et puis il ya des gens qui
sont abonnés depuis avons rangé à france
télécom depuis 10 ans 15 ans 30 ans
enfin bon donc voilà sachant que la
fibre va quand même probablement et les
réseaux ou la partir elle arrange arles
qui est des réseaux qui a été fait sur
elle les abonnés précédent et que le
financement des abonnés précédent mais
également sur financement public il faut
quand même se souvenir d'eux de cela
aussi pour l'instant quand on parle des
anciens réseaux téléphoniques et les
réseaux téléphonie ont parlé du préau
des 10 alors on a parlé de des tuyaux et
maintenant il faut aussi parler de ce
qu'il ya dedans la création de cette
société ludovic rochette par les cons
six des huit conseils généraux de
bourgogne franche comté c'est aussi
l'idée de pouvoir aller voir les
opérateurs parce que en fait ce que les
gens savent pas c'est que dans le très
haut débit c'est double peine il va
falloir trouver un opérateur il ya
plusieurs raisons première raison c'est
bien sûr créé l'appétence auprès des
opérateurs deuxième raison il ya aussi
des aides bonifié de l'état lorsque on a
une démarche qui est supra
départementale c'est l'ordre pour nous 3
millions d'euros donc c'est pas un
argument naudin ancien
pour chaque département a fait on a une
idée c'est difficile à dire en moyenne
combien alors vous évoluiez tout à
l'heure ce que ça pouvait couper pour la
nièvre qui est un département étendue
rural vous disiez 256 à 250 millions
d'euros la côte d'or vous avez si on met
la fibre à chaque abonné c'est de
l'ordre de 256 millions d'euros nous la
première tranche ses 75 millions d'euros
environ avec les deux techniques ont
évoqué au début de l'émission est-ce
qu'il ya le risque que une fois que les
collectivités auront installé la fibre
opérateurs fois pas très intéressé par
par vos appels d'offres se passe pas
exactement comme sarah c'est à dire on
va trouver un opérateur qui à vouloir
exploiter
c'est à dire celles exploitant
l'autoroute en quelque sorte c'est pas
l'opérateur qui s'est pas la voiture qui
roule c'est donc c'est l'exploitant de
on va le trouver mais après avec un
niveau de redevance qu'il va payer sur
l'investissement qui va être plus ou
moins élevé c'est sain à des ajustements
de l'équilibré économique de
l'investissement qu'on va réaliser et
notre idée c'est plus on fait une offre
groupée plus on se paie espérer que elle
sera intéressante pour l'exploitant est
donc plus le niveau de la redevance pour
simplifier les choses qu'il aura à payer
aux collectivités en remboursant
l'investissement serait important avec
un taux de pénétration qui sera
normalement supérieure dans ces zones là
que dans les zones qui ont actuellement
le triple play c'est à dire l'internet
haut débit que l'asie est ce que je me
trompe si je dis quand même que cette
coopération entre conseils
départementaux de droite et de gauche
c'est presque une nouveauté ou s'est
quasiment jamais arrivé c'est déjà être
pragmatique et puis on est comme dans
une situation où on n'a pas le droit de
se regarder et de faire de la
philosophie de techniques à savoir si le
wimax était bien ou pas bien à savoir si
le nerf a été bien ou pas bien
aujourd'hui en situations où on a un pan
de énorme de nos territoires abandonnés
donc on a pas il faut bien qu'on agisse
aujourd'hui mon compère souvent quand
même à mais sur des sujets dont les
volumes financiers soient moins
importants sur des questions
territoriales je pense au parc du morvan
où il ya département les quatre les
quatre départements la région sur un
certain nombre de sujets concernant le
développement de telle ou telle activité
on est on travaille ensemble mais là
effectivement l'enjeu est financier
nécessite évidemment qu'on ait un
rapprochement encore beaucoup plus
étroit que sur d'autres sujets parce que
l'on je le mérite
rarement en services et en financement
convient de trouver un point positif on
n'accusera pas de chercher négatif
benoît vidaud on vient de parler de
coopération entre collectivités est ce
que par exemple ce type de d'enjeu ça
pousse aussi les collectivités
maintenant à regarder un peu plus vers
vous vers le monde de l'entreprise
est-ce que vous avez des échanges là
dessus ou est-ce que ça se passe pas
très bien avec les collectivités
sinon ce nous sommes des échanges
évidemment on est toujours et toujours
les premiers à venir toquer à la porte
de nos élus pour leur faire part de nos
mécontentements sur l'irrigation de
l'internet mais aujourd'hui les
programmes qui sont annoncées vont dans
le bon sens
la coopération est d aider pour nous
naturelle naturelle depuis depuis depuis
toujours avec les élus locaux
l'avancement est un petit peu plus
compliqué aujourd'hui ce programme il va
voir le jour pour la ruralité c'est bien
pour dijon et encore d'autres choses à
faire évoluer on voudrait qu'une
coopération soit peut-être plus forte
mais moi je dirais je j'irai pas vers
les collectivités je voudrais qu'avec
orange on se rencontre la cgpme de
côte-d'or et puis qu'on puisse expliquer
à l'opérateur national lancé
l'invitation ici à je lance aux
votations on la voit régulièrement à la
malienne c'est dommage qu'elle soit pas
là aujourd'hui j'aurais bien aimé
qu'elle soit là pour nous expliquer
pourquoi et c'est vraiment dommage parce
qu'il manque un interlocuteur majeur
dans le débat etc c'est là c'est surtout
vers cet interlocuteur que nous pme nous
avons l'habitude de nous retourner et
d'essayer de faire évoluer les choses
quand c'est pas possible ben tant mieux
il ya aujourd'hui des sociétés qui
existe et d'une belle pme est une pme
qui
c'est une association c'est quoi ça ne
s'est pas une entreprise qu'on puisse
donc avec tant mieux il ya des gens qui
prennent qui saisissent la balle au bond
pour pouvoir aider les entreprises à
répondre à leurs besoins mais mais oui
vraiment une coopération avec orange est
importante ou un autre ainsi ses parents
je serai un autre mais il faut que ça
puisse développer le territoire d'abord
vous êtes une association d une
association donc c'est vraiment un côté
bénévoles absolue qui prime sur tout ça
quand j'entends les élus qui nous disent
qu'ils veulent travailler ensemble au
moins sur le numérique je trouve ça ça
super intéressant je dois quand même me
signifie qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya des
périodes électorales on reçoit une
flopée de coups de fil d'élus qui nous
disent oui c'est génial on veut vous
aider on veut on peut apprendre d'eux
joue on veut avancer parce que 10 dont
on n'est vraiment pas bien sur le
numérique et après les élections souvent
ça retombe un peu comme un souffle et
c'est bien dommage donc j'espère que
vous allez travailler bien dansant pour
faire avancer ce numéro pour tous voilà
ça va être le moment de la vouli dire
quelque chose avant qu'on passe en
question et d'un crochet des territoires
dont on n'a pas trop parlé non plus ce
sont ce qu'on appelle les écarts les
fermes isolées vraiment perdu
difficile d'accès là aussi il faut être
pragmatique par rapport aux techniques
il existe des kits satellitaires qui
peuvent faire
être intéressant sur sur quelques années
le temps que la fibre arrive assure
signe sur ses instincts trajet
renforcera les derniers installés bien
sûr voilà c'est ce qu'on vous a proposé
attention parce que sur le celi vous
avez raison à ce une solution possible
effectivement quand on n'a pas besoin de
pas de forte consommation de données et
pour des activités d'entreprise
notamment autour une forte besoin de
passer de la donnée dans un sens ou dans
l'autre ça marche pas parce que j'ai une
proposition qui a été faite justement
l'occasion de cette rencontre je suis
désolé de le rappeler mais auprès d'un
gestionnaires de campings et s'est
aperçu qu effectivement je crois que la
benoîte à 39,59 euros par avoir une
activité provincial pourquoi pas mais
s'est aperçu que compte tenu du fait
qu'il accueillait 200 personnes sur son
camping si joliment se connecter au même
moment est dit et justement il ya
beaucoup de bande passante beaucoup de
données donc de transférer ça pourrait
lui coûter par mois plus de 1000 euros
donc attention aussi c'est une solution
qui est adapté pour des écarts pour des
particuliers pour des entreprises
beaucoup plus difficile en grèce est la
réponse que la vision ce que je voulais
faire alors notre débat notre discussion
a mené à sa tombe de réactions sur
internet je vais dire en plaisantant
pour ceux qui avaient suffisamment fr
faibles vont pouvoir prouver à l'avion
il y en a qui sont quand même arriver
quelqu'un nous dit que ça ne marche qu'à
week-end sur deux chez lui on a eu de la
chance parce que c'était bon week-end
pour nous répondre aujourd'hui mais
voilà on nous parle de l'ain aussi
départements pilotes manifestement sur
sur ce sujet qu'elle le plus grand mal à
trouver un opérateur une fois que les
installations ont été faites c'est ce
que nous décrit quelqu'un qui
manifestement connaît de connaît le
sujet
une remarque de quelqu'un de l'yonne qui
manifestement a lu les journaux aussi
sur le sujet qui nous dit d'après les
médias l'installation dû haut débit
alors va coûter 40 millions non c'est là
c'est les investissements annoncés 40
millions mais ça coûtera bien sûr
beaucoup plus cher que 40 millions et la
personne nous dit il faut une taxe sur
les opérateurs dans la nouvelle loi pour
les obliger à financer en partie de
réseaux qu'est ce que vous en pensez pas
très joli je suis une bonne idée mais je
votre constat il n'ya pas de raison qui
va l'écrire dans la loi puisque les
contributions qu'il n'y ait pas une
solidarité justement entre les
territoires oubliés ou fait que certains
sont très rentables autres d'autres le
sont moins c'est ce que offrirait en
fait un seul opérateur public national
cette solidarité territoriale car vous
n'y croyez pas
mais en revanche face une dit quand même
que j'ai en tête depuis longtemps c'est
à dire si tous les opérateurs publics
réunie comme nous allons lettres en
bourgogne et en franche comté se
réunissaient il ya des moyens aussi de
mutualiser les réseaux il ya une manière
d'apporter une réponse et surtout de
créer un opérateur qui soient dans le
monde des opérateurs avec une autre
philosophie notre approche celle du
service rendu c'était le congrès des
départements france cette semaine vous
en avait parlé on n'a pas parlé parce
qu'il ya des contraintes albums genres
qu'ils seront nos contraintes
financières et qui s'ajoute aujourd'hui
qui s'ajoute au fait qu'on a à financer
de nouveaux investissements
indispensables pour nous était plutôt
sur les questions sociales dans le
conseiller social et de compensation à
la taxe benoît vidaud elle rêvait pas
que vous verrez faire attention à cette
taxe parce que finalement une taxe à mon
avis ça peut être une solution mais
finalement c'est l'entreprise et le
particulier qui la paiera donc le prix
le prix d'internet en sera revu donc
attention attention aux effets pervers
d'une nouvelle taxe et quand on omet de
nouvelles taxes nous dans nos pme
effectivement il ya quelqu'un qui la
paye à la fin c'est le fond mais
quelqu'un qui serait pas d'accord
300 opérateurs
internet en connaît bien sûr les
migrants ont fait partie d'une
fédération la fdn qui regroupe aussi des
fournisseurs d'accès associatif
disséminés partout donc la taxe est
gentil mais alors faut mettre des
paliers avec des chiens de race et on
verra
l'intervention publique se fait sur un
beau public aujourd'hui donc d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est du
financement à travers l'impôt direct ou
indirect mais je pense quand même que
prélever sur une part de bénéfices
d'orange ou de sfr et compagnie moi ça
me gêne pas plus que ça alors une
question spécifique pour ludovic
rochette puisque c'est une côte
d'orienne qui nous écrit dans ma rue
nous sommes quatre maisons ne pas avoir
de ligne fixe donc encore moins
d'internet qui doit se charger de faire
les travaux de connexion un coton
sachant que devant chez nous il n'y a
plus de place ils font quoi ces gens la
méfiance et des maisons qui ne sont pas
connectés au réseau
intervient dans ce cas là le maire le
conseil départemental si on veut élargir
un peu alors normalement il ya
l'opérateur qui en jeu dans l'histoire
il a l'air loin de chez eux et
puis bah après tout dépend quelle est la
commune mais si la commune est concernée
dans le cadre de la première phase du
déploiement du haut débit par la montée
en débit ou par le ftth
l'intervention du département peut
exister tout dépend quelle quelle est la
clé un endroit donné mais on va poser la
question cédric colson on a plein de
questions sur donnez-nous les
coordonnées pc lite on vous trouve sur
les réseaux sociaux sur internet
on ne trouve sur les réseaux sociaux on
pas pour pc life et puis sur internet ww
pour apc live.fr on répondra et plaisir
de répondre aux gens vous êtes
qu'après votre émission est un peu
submergés mais j'ai mes collègues qui
sera un plaisir de répondre aussi
sur le site du congrès départemental à
partir du milieu de la semaine prochaine
il sera possible effectivement pour tous
les nivernais d'indiquer précisément là
où ils sont quels problèmes ils ont en
matière d'internet de manière quelle est
l'offre opérateurs de manière à ce qu'on
puisse identifier l'ensemble des
situations et à l'interpeller opérateurs
on aura comme sa grandeur nature
l'ensemble des problèmes qui ont pu qui
peuvent exister sur le département ça se
fait que si l'on pousse la connaissez
pas pour l'instant du site du conseil
départemental au milieu de la semaine
prochaine il y aura ça en ligne et ça
nous permettra d'avoir précisément des
informations dont on ne dispose pas
toujours et en tout cas qu'on nous cache
sur la qualité du service effectivement
rendu quand même manière je fais la
publicité de thd côte d'or il permet de
voir le déploiement du haut débit sur
tout départements et avec le planning
précis est ce que vous pensez qu'il va y
avoir parce que là ce que vous nous
dites ça préfigure quelque chose ou pas
c'est à dire on sent qu'il ya quelque
chose qui remuent qui bouge pour de ça
au tour du très haut débit au tour de
patrice joly née des pensées que les
départements ça peut être une quelque
chose de moteurs de quel point de vue du
préfet vous pour essayer de se fédérer
peut-être de ne pas rester isolé chacun
dans son coin face par exemple aux
grands opérateurs historiques amour on a
créé la semaine dernière une association
qui s'appelle l'association nationale
des nouvelles ruralités le grand paris
s'en est ce à dire le pari de la france
c'est peut-être celui des territoires
ruraux c'est celui d'un équipement
correct des élites et des territoires
ruraux on veut peser sur le numérique
mais sur d'autres sujets justement sur
les politiques publiques des poulets
ployer et vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs qui doivent intervenir sur
le territoire merci à tous les quatre
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'être venus débattre on suivra bien sûr
tout ce que vous allez faire sur ce
sujet rendez vous samedi prochain même
heure même endroit bon week-end au roi